yes exactly here I'm with Wesley Wesley
the tournament is over for you right now
after this draw against Yani pishi so
what happened today what was your plan
for the game my plan well I'm not
exactly happy with the way the
tournament has gone and also now that
it's finished like not exactly totally
pleased with my performance but uh it is
what it is I mean I had a a very tough
day yesterday I had an off day
basically I prepared some lines but I
never expected Fabiano to play the eer
name so again against me so I didn't
look at it uh and that's basically the
moral for me when playing against
Fabiano like it's better just to sleep
or watch a movie or read a book and not
prepare at all because every single time
I play him for classical I would
prepare like for example on black I
would prepare against one E4 and then he
play D4 or I would prepare against one
D4 and then he play C4 so he just every
time I prepare against Fabiano it ends
up in a disaster so I knew it was going
to happen yesterday like I would prepare
something and he' play something
totally surprising that I didn't expect
but
uh uh you know I I I didn't stick to the
plan yeah I know this crazy feeling is
when you spend so many hours on prep and
then your opponent plays something
completely different yes it was uh it
was much easier a few years ago because
fabbi is primarily an one E4 player and
he would always go one E4 so at least I
kind of know what to expect but uh he's
a really good player and that's a
problem like he can play anything and
also he's got very deep preparation so
it's and also he's a decent he's a very
good chess player so it's makes it
really difficult to prepare against
think that's better not to prepare at
all yeah so you think the let's say
yesterday's game was the most decisive
for your tournament and today it was not
sure so yeah but I mean to be honest uh
leevon aronian also gave me a free gift
in in our game like he he also blundered
by playing C5 in the end game so
yesterday I blundered terribly I mixes
up the opening like uh I played the line
which I don't I've ever played before
yesterday and it's very complex and I
haven't checked it in a few months so
then it's hard really to to to do
something if you if you don't remember
right yeah people say chess is very
drawish and they are right in a way but
it's also there's a lot of lines to to
memorize and when you mix up with move
your move order and opening you can can
pay very dearly so chess is not as easy
as it look from the outside not it's not
easy at all don't ask me twice to this
yeah people think oh yeah draw draw draw
equal I think but but you have actually
have to remember quite a bit in the
opening so now with with the situation
let's say you don't play in the last
round so can we a little bit think of
what can happen which scenarios will
will can can be good for you not so good
for you because still Fabby has to play
tomorrow one more game and same for
linear today he has to play this
position against maiman then he has one
more round well again I'm not
very pleased with the a quick draw today
it's not exactly what I want but uh uh
it is what it is and it's hard to play
your best after a a loss yes so I think
I have really good chances
to or I think pretty much guaranteed to
finish in the top TI in the grand CH T
and Y can correct me if I'm wrong but uh
I think so yes and maybe like the worst
case scenario if you have to play uh
playoff right I don't know if it's
possible no I don't think there's a
playoff because if you look at the
grandchester standing I think unless I'm
I've lost my mind I think I'm like
19.7 and uh there's always always all
these points so there's no there's no
chance of good so congratulate you
already that you achieved your goal I
remember you told me before the
tournament that the most important for
you is to make sure you play the next
grest tour okay I'm not a, % sure but I
think I'm pretty confident unless
something crazy happens but lightning
doesn't strike twice at the same place
but I mean I of course it's my priority
because uh and I'd like to thank the
opportunity to thank the organizers and
the sponsors of the grandest store
because I've been playing in this
tournament since I was a kid you know
since
2015 and every single year I play in the
grand Chester and uh the tournaments are
so well organized it's very professional
and the the players are really really
strong and I love the format as of the
rapid and Blitz uh I just you know my
mom and I love the grandchester so it's
uh it's really my goal you know to start
qualify every year and I hope I do
exactly my last question like was this
season 2023 in some way special for you
what Memories you will have this one
well it's you know it's it's another
year you it's uh great to be back over
to playing over the board chess uh after
the pandemic years I wasn't sure things
would go back normal but they seem
pretty much are uh well I played a lot
of tournaments this year uh it's been
not exactly what I expected what I hoped
for in the beginning but uh I had a lot
of fun I I played in W played in
dorf played also very nice uh rapid and
Blitz tournament in Amsterdam the
levitov is one of the best tournaments I
ever played in I played a great Bliss
tournament in Berlin twice uh and with
World CH yes yes so I mean it was we had
the world rapid end team yes exactly yes
many events and you became the world
champion also with the team yes Wesley
so so it's it's it's been a it's been a
fun it's been a fun year it's been a lot
of events and uh I know I had a I had a
great time you know I love I love
playing CH and uh uh you know I'll do it
again a heartbeat not not exactly doing
it for money but for the love the game
and it's work you know it's a it's a i
the the only thing I hate about Chess is
being stuck in airplanes and airports
like you you kill you kill a lot
of time in your life yeah but uh but
once you get to the place it's uh it's
wonderful and uh we're grateful to St
Louis for for helping have a career yeah
thank you Wesley so much and all the
best of luck for you in the end of this
year and for the next season yeah maybe
I also have an outside chance of
qualifying for the candidates if I
didn't lose yesterday it would have been
big chance but we'll see what it happens
uh but um yeah it's still open question
at the moment yes all the best of luck
in this two for you yeah for sure thank
you thank you and we are going back to
the studio thank you Anastasia